[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENRY HARDING: My
name's Henry Harding.
I'm in the agency Go-to-Market
team supporting the GCast
Agency team.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
I'm just going to introduce
my good friend Andy.
He's been a member of or a
part of the LGBT activist
community and the Democratic
political community
for the past 40-plus years.
And beyond that, he
also wrote the book
that is on the chair
in front of you,
which you're happy to take.
He was the author of "The
Best Little Boy in the World,"
which is a landmark memoir
about growing up gay.
He claims that he
invented the password
hint, which I do not believe.
And he also-- fun fact-- was
one of the original investors
in "Nunsense."
So if sort of like nun parody
musicals are your thing,
then you should definitely
ask Andy all about it.
But with that, I'm just
going to let him come on up
and talk to you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDY TOBIAS: Thank you.
Thank you.
It's so fun to be here.
I love Google.
Some of you I know.
Some of you I don't.
Those of you I know,
you've heard these stories
over and over and over again.
And we don't want to jeopardize
Google's (c)(3) status.
You are a nonprofit, right?
But Henry left
out the 18 years I
was treasurer of the Democratic
National Committee until,
like, five minutes
ago, because he doesn't
want to jeopardize the status.
But those of you who are
strong Trump supporters,
raise your hands now so I
be more careful what I say.
OK, got that out of the way.
So I want to just
talk for a few minutes
and then open up to questions
for whatever you want,
because that's more fun.
But I was sort of tasked with
LGBT activism or whatever
over the years, the decades,
since the last millennium
and before any of you--
long before your
parents were born.
By the way, I turned 70 a
month ago, and it is great.
And I want you to know that--
I mean, this is important.
I mean, don't rush
it, but you are
going to have such a
great time when you're 70.
And you can't imagine that now.
I mean, you figure 30 is
going to be a nightmare.
But it's so great.
OK, so it wasn't always
this easy to be gay.
And I'm still not
all that good at it,
but in 1973, I had
the courage to write
under a pen name this book.
This is the original hardcover.
The publisher was so
horrified, the sales force was
so horrified that the publisher
had done this thing that they
basically tried to
suppress it and wouldn't.
But there hadn't been a
book like this for kind
of coming out for boys.
I didn't use my real name
because in 1973, some people
were brave.
I've never been brave.
I'm still not brave.
Anybody know who
Frank Kameny was?
See, I mean, Frank
Kameny is our hero.
And a woman named Barbara
Gittings, our hero.
Frank Kameny and Barbara
Gittings and 10 other people
marched around the
White House in 1965,
four years before Stonewall
and all this kind of stuff,
with signs basically saying,
I'm homosexual, and my rights--
gay is good, and you
should respect my rights.
I'm an American citizen.
They were better
signs than that.
But can you imagine the
courage to do that where
everybody hated you, except the
few people who secretly were
in the same situation,
but they pretended
to hate you even more so that
they wouldn't be found out?
Anyway, the world
was very different.
So I did this thing.
And I do these every 25 years.
So this is 1973, and then
the sequel came out in 1998.
It was called "The Best Little
Boy in the World Grows Up,"
which is quite arguable.
I'm not sure-- I'm
still basically 12.
And now I'm working
on the trequel, which
Henry will certainly be
in, and other friends.
The reason for the
investment book, by the way,
is you're all going
to be so rich,
and I want you to spend it well.
And I'm basically a
writer, not a talker,
so I figure, if
give you the book,
if I don't do this part
well, it's not my problem.
You've got a book.
How often do you do that?
And this is a book that's going
to make you so rich, so OK.
So what I wanted to do, which I
actually had never done before,
so it may or may not
work, but I'm working
on the trequel, the third one.
And I wrote a little
bit of it that I
thought might be
fun, just for you
to get a sense of what life
was like way back then for me
to start.
And then I'll stop
with reading things
and tell you a few more things.
Where'd it go?
But do you all know
the Broadway subway
line that goes all the
way up to 242nd Street?
I guess it's the 1?
Somebody probably
takes it from wherever.
Do you all live in Brooklyn?
Anybody live in Manhattan?
And how many people know
who Barney Frank is?
OK, so Barney was chairman of
the House Financial Services
Committee.
Dodd-Frank is Barney Frank
and all that kind of stuff.
Anyway, so in the
new book, which
may be called "The Best Little
Boy in the World Gets Cranky,"
but I'm not really cranky.
Bernie Sanders is cranky.
He's a wonderful man,
but he is cranky.
If you ever meet him,
he's a cranky man.
But whatever the
title is, I'm going
to have kind of normal chapters.
But then I think
I'm going to have
alternative histories,
kind of in between some
of the chapters of how the
world would have been different
if just one little thing
had been different,
such as 77,000 votes in this
last election, or whatever,
but OK.
And the main reason
I'm reading this
is just to give you a
sense of what it was like.
And some of you even-- it's
not all that easy these days.
I don't know where you all
grew up, but for some of you,
it was probably the
simplest thing in the world.
Everybody at [INAUDIBLE] was
gay, or straight, or didn't
care, and it was fine.
And the one of you who's
here from Mississippi,
it was a nightmare, and
your parents kicked you out,
even though it was just three
years ago, and all that stuff.
So it's still not all that easy.
But in 1964, it was
really not easy.
The other reason I
want to read this
is just to say how
lucky I've been
and how much luck has to do with
so much of people's success.
And so when we encounter people
who aren't as fortunate as we
are, it's not just because
we're so much smarter and better
looking.
It may be a little bit because
this thing didn't happen
that I'm about to read you.
This is an alternative history.
"So I'm on the
subway, on the way
to school on an
unusually warm April
day at the end of my
senior year, attache case
behind the calves of my chinos.
I know, what kind of
kid wears a jacket
and tie to school, an
all-male school, no less,
let alone with an attache case?
Do you even know what
an attache case is?
Was I some sort of attache?
No, but it was 1964.
I was co-editor of the
high school yearbook.
Lots of prep schools and
country day schools and colleges
back then were all boys or
all girls, as Horace Mann was.
No, I was not molested."
Any of you go to Horace
Mann, by the way?
OK, but you know that
they have this huge--
"No, I was not molested, but
knew almost all the teachers
who, decades later, would make
the front page of the 'New York
Times.'
Backpacks had not yet
been invented, at least
not in our household, and I
had been up most of the night
finishing the last third of the
yearbook, laying out the photos
and making the crop
marks so that they'd
fit the pages and
the text, all this
with paper and rubber cement."
Anybody know what
rubber cement is?
Probably not.
"And red pencil and the
kinds of things that would be
rendered obsolete minutes
later with Quark and Photoshop
and all the rest.
Back then, the world
still used hot type,
better than how the
monks hand-lettered
Bibles or the block letters
Gutenberg or Ben Franklin used.
In a blink of time,
we've gone from all that
to all but effortless,
all-but-free typesetting
and book design.
But I digress.
Look it up-- hot
type, molten lead.
The thing is, as sleep-deprived
as I was, I was elated.
This was it, the final
third of the yearbook
ready to hand the
printer that day,
the final several
weeks of the final year
of a six-year endeavor soon
to culminate in graduation.
Six years is a long time to
an 11-year-old just turned
17 and about to graduate, six
years of stress to perform well
in class and on tests and on
the soccer field, terrified
of running into an
opposing player,
though that was what
we were supposed to do.
And in the pool, swimming
a mile each morning,
72 laps before class many
days, the only one in the pool.
And on the wrestling
mat, after Coach Cramp--"
which was his real name.
He was the swimming
coach, Coach Cramp--
"after Coach Cramp decided
I would never get fast
and handed me off to
Coach Quinn, who thought,
wrongly, I might
make a good wrestler,
which really terrified me
on more than one level.
But how could I let on?
But all that was behind me.
I had made it.
Spring had sprung.
[INAUDIBLE] tulips
were in bloom--
tech would 50 years later make
that front-page story as part
of the scandal--
and Harvard loomed.
Once more, I had managed to
catch the train Neil Landau was
on, the bad boy in our
class with whom, therefore,
I was desperately in love.
He would be kicked
out a few weeks later,
after those same six years
of stress and struggle,
just days before
graduation, for smoking.
Not even weed-- we didn't know
such things then-- tobacco.
And not even on
campus, down at Lou
and Tito's soda shop at the
base of the stairs of the subway
at Broadway and 242nd Street.
Granted, it wasn't his
only infraction, merely
the last straw.
But that's what the
world was like in 1964,
at least at Horace Mann.
You could be
expelled for smoking.
Imagine what would have happened
to you for being homosexual.
Or so I imagined, more
or less constantly,
which is why 10 minutes would
never pass without my checking
to make sure I was
adequately hiding
my secret, which I knew I would
have to hide all my life."
A couple years ago,
I flew to China
and came out with
Nixon's grandson.
I mean, Nixon's
grandson I assume
is straight, but came out to
the vice president of China
and the whole top of the
Communist Party of China.
But at the time, "I
would have to hide
all my life, a life that I
couldn't imagine extending much
beyond the safety of
my all-boys school
and the all-male college
for which I was bound.
Was I checking out the girls on
the subway when my friends did?
Was I being adequately
jockish to fool everybody?
But oh, how in love
I was with Neil,
who was as close as our class
could come to a juvenile
delinquent-- not
very close at all.
And whether it was one
of those mornings when,
my having boarded the
train at 66th Street,
he simply got on at
79th, or one of those
when his not having boarded
at 79th, I got off at 86th
and took the next train so
I was to accidentally come
upon him as I went through car
to car looking for a good seat.
However it happened
that particular morning
that we were on the same
train, there he had been.
And as he and I and a
couple of other classmates
finally got 242nd
Street, clattering down
the 112 steps to
the street level,
marveling at the summer
weather and ducking
into Lou and Tito's for a
coffee or vanilla egg cream
before class, I was
basically in heaven.
Could it get better than this?
Neil, the weather, Harvard
acceptance, yearbook completed?
[GASPS] Which is when a
horror gripped me like none
I had ever felt before.
The yearbook-- the yearbook
that the entire school looked
forward to on class day, the
yearbook that the five prior
editions of which I,
like all my classmates,
had on my shelf at home
chronicling our youthful
progress, the yearbook my older
brother Goliath had edited
before he went off to
Harvard four years earlier--
and not co-editor
either, like me,
which was a source of no small
shame to me, who had to share
his glory with Larry [? Jay. ?]
The yearbook all my
classmates and I and faculty
would shortly be writing
little notes to each other in.
What would I write in Neil's?
What would he write in mine?
The yearbook that would shortly
be the talk of the school,
because for the first time
in Horace Mann's then 75-year
history, it had color
end pages and photos
throughout the previously
boring ad pages.
I would get
advertiser permission
to sponsor pages of
photos above their logo.
Had I chosen too many sports
photos, too many wrestling
photos, too many of Neil?
The yearbook, the final third
of which, decades before backups
and Dropbox, was in my attache
case ready for the printer.
Where was it?
I had been so taken
with the morning,
and with Neil, and with
our impending freedom,
I had left it on the train.
In a city of 8 million
and a subway system
of 425 miles of track,
electrified by adrenalin
at levels never
before experienced,
I bounded back up
those 112 stairs
in the slim hope the train
might still be in the station.
242nd Street was, after
all, the last stop,
so it would sit there
for a few minutes
before taking on passengers
for the long trip back south.
The platform was empty.
My life was very possibly over.
I instinctively kept
running all the way
to the end of the station,
as if to catch the train,
or perhaps outrun it to 238th
Street, where it would next
stop.
And I ran all the way
to the control tower
I had never, in
six years of riding
the train to that station,
really paid attention
to and had certainly
never entered.
I ran up those
stairs, wild-eyed,
hoping against hope that they
could perhaps stop the train.
There were a couple
of guys up there
manning the tower,
one of whom turned
to me as I burst
in and said words
that changed my life forever.
Are you looking for this?
It seems they do a
walk-through at the end
of the line for
garbage and dead bodies
or whatever had been
lost and might be found.
Can I just say that
if they hadn't,
or that if they had just
tossed it in the trash,
or if it had been kept
for its attache value
but the contents
tossed in the trash,
I can't say for sure what my
life would have been like,
but it would have
been very different.
Conceivably, on some level,
I would have been forgiven.
Conceivably Harvard would not
have rescinded my admission.
But even then, and
who's to say, I
would have been
forevermore the guy who
ran the wrong way at the
championship game and seconds
before victory scored a
touchdown for the other team.
We all know that guy.
The first guy in
Horace Mann history--
and Horace Mann history was
a big deal to a boy like me--
to have torpedoed the yearbook
that the staff had worked
so hard on, that
had cost so much--
color end plates did
not come cheap in 1964--
and that the entire school
had been looking forward
to keeping for the
rest of their lives.
This would be the defining
moment for the best little boy
in the world?
And even though they
were entirely unrelated--
but wait, no, they
weren't unrelated.
I had committed this
colossal catastrophe because
of my desperate love
for the unsuspecting,
in truth not tremendously
bright, but wonderful,
miraculous Neil Landau.
So there was linkage.
And maybe somebody, somehow
would figure it out.
Presumably not, but
even so, I would know.
The guilt and shame would
have been overwhelming.
Unclean, people
would have shouted,
pointing as
leperously I slunk by.
My happy gene might have seen me
through"-- more on that later--
"but I might today
be sleeping over
a subway grate in the
winter, on a park bench
the rest of the year.
Perhaps in an
ultimate time travel,
alternate reality irony,
the very bench that, as life
turned out I wound up
naming for Charles,
who was for 17 years my
partner, and Henry knew.
But he handed me
the attache case.
My heartbeat eventually
returned to normal.
The yearbook was a huge success.
No one knew that I had
that other terrible secret.
And though I've certainly had
a few disappointments, one just
now when I looked to see what
Neil did write in my yearbook
and see that he wrote nothing,
and even a little heartbreak,
I try never, ever to
forget how lucky I've been,
in 1,000 ways."
Remind me to tell you.
In fact, remind me to
tell you about John Rawls
and why Warren
Buffett is a Democrat.
"I count my aggressive
atheist little blessings
quarter-hourly."
So I've been very lucky.
The world was so different back
then that to have been gay,
I mean, it was all-consuming.
So I go to Harvard, and I am
the only gay person at Harvard.
Probably not really true,
probably about 2,000 others,
but how would you know?
They couldn't know about me.
I couldn't know about them.
My junior year, I realized
that there was one other,
because he was looking
at the same guys I was.
And he was the resident
tutor in our dorm.
And everybody loved him.
He was such a character.
He was fat and
hard to understand.
He had a big cigar.
Motherficker this, motherfucker
that, all this kind of stuff.
But he was so smart, and he
was so interested in politics,
and he would do battle with--
the tables were for eight, and
there would be 10 or 12 or 14
people all crowded around
with their trays of food
on their laps so they
could hear this guy.
And they would do battle
with him, and none of them
could come close.
And these were
smart-- most of them--
smart guys.
And I noticed he was kind
of paying special attention
to the people that I was
paying special attention to.
And I went, oh my god,
there's one other person.
Why does it have to be him?
I mean, he's wonderful
and popular, but no.
Why can't it be one of
my roommates, two of whom
I was in love with?
One went on to be
mayor of Cincinnati,
and another went
dean of students
at the University
of British Columbia.
And now they know
all about my life
and all this kind of stuff.
We're still friends.
But no, just this guy, OK.
That was 1967-ish.
Cut to-- what is it now--
four or five years ago.
And we never talked
about it back in college,
and it'll be years
before either one of us
came out or did
anything about it.
We just kind of were so
lonely and so yearning on.
Eventually we became
aware and all that stuff.
So now it's five
years ago, and I
am one of the groomsman
in his wedding.
He's no longer a resident
tutor at Harvard.
His wedding in Massachusetts,
in attendance are Nancy Pelosi
and I think John
Kerry and all that.
His name was Barney
Frank, and he went on
to become chairman of the House
Financial Services Committee.
And he had been totally lonely,
the only gay person at Harvard,
in his mind.
I was totally all that.
That's how much the
world has changed.
And you know all
this, and you saw
the president of
the United States
in the second inaugural
talking about our journey
is not complete.
From Selma to Stonewall, and
Seneca Falls to Stonewall,
it's so amazing what's changed.
But it took a long time.
So one of the things I remember
is in the '70s, after I--
so I finally came
out when I was 23.
And you could write
a book about it.
And people had to use pen names,
and they had to be careful.
And when they went
to Fire Island,
they wouldn't call
collect from the pay phone
because it would
say Fire Island,
and they couldn't
have people know
that they were on Fire Island.
Even though there are actually
quite a few communities
in Fire Island
that are straight,
it still could be
a telltale sign.
You could lose your job.
You could all kinds of stuff.
And we had, I remember, somebody
trying to get me involved.
I was still only
26 or something.
And one of the old people--
32 or whatever--
Henry appears to be 27, but
I think you're 32, right?
Something like that.
So these old guys all trying
to get me involved, and we
had a little group called
[? Nypack, ?] I think
is what it was called.
And we would meet with people
running for office, including
somebody who wanted to become
governor one day, Andrew Cuomo.
And these politicians
would have to come.
Some of us wouldn't
even use our last names.
I was writing for "New
York" magazine back then
under my real name,
but the excerpts
of "The Best Little
Boy in the World"
were under the pen
name, because again, I'm
very brave and courageous.
And you could see,
I mean, Cuomo,
it was not comfortable for him.
And I don't blame him.
It was 1976 or whatever it was.
But we've come so far.
I'd rather leave the
Don't Ask, Don't Tell
and DOMA and anything
you want to--
trans stuff and whatever you
want to talk about to Q and A.
I just want to tell
you two more things.
You have now the only investment
guide you'll ever need--
I mean ever.
But it's a little
embarrassing to have
to revise it every five
or six years, which I do,
because they do things like they
invent the internet, you know,
where gold is no longer
fixed at $35 an ounce by law.
So the basics never change,
but some of the details do.
But in addition to the only
investment guide you'll ever
need, I've written
the only relationship
guide you'll ever need.
And since this is
possibly the only time
I will get to meet you,
although some of you, I hope,
are going to come on Wednesday
to meet Joe Biden and all that,
and others will be in my pool
on July 4th for a lobster.
Henry will give you
all the details.
In case this is the
only time I see you,
you need to know what little
I know about relationships.
I didn't give you that
book, the only relationship
guide you'll ever need,
because it's only one sentence.
And even I wasn't--
there's not a large
enough font in the world
to justify putting that in a
book and charging $14 for it.
But this actually, for
what it's worth, to me,
this is kind of 80% of it.
The other 20%, you could
write books and books
and books and books.
But 80% of it is be
nice to each other,
as I'm sure you already are, and
find humor in the compromises,
as I'm sure you already do--
they're worth it.
And those of you who
are in relationships,
I know one of you, and
I know your partner
and all that stuff.
I mean, Charles and
I were so different.
He couldn't spell or
punctuate or add or subtract.
But he could make--
Mister, you probably have some
of his clothes in your closet.
If you have any Ellen Tracy or
Anne Klein or Charles Nolan,
you have his clothes.
He could make
anything look good.
We were once at a thing
where Arianna Huffington
had to be the Queen of
England for a little skit
that we were doing at a big
thing, but with no notice.
And our little team, she had
to be the Queen of England.
And everybody looked
to Charles because he
was going to figure it out.
And he said, all right,
get me a tablecloth
and a container of tinfoil.
And they went to the kitchen
and found their thing.
She looked more like the Queen
of England than the queen.
Anyway, so Charles
was amazing that way.
I can't draw a straight line.
I can't draw a curvy line.
I have no fashion
sense whatsoever,
as you can see,
on and on and on.
But we found humor
in the compromises.
Anyway, so that's that part.
The other thing I want to
tell you is what motivates me
and why--
and this is going to
sound corny, I'm sure,
to most of you,
but I believe it.
I believe that after 10,000
human generations, which
is about what it's been, right?
20 years divided into 200,000
years or so of humans--
10,000 human generations
of struggling and suffering
and shivering and itching
and smelling horrible
and being terrified
of saber-tooth tigers
and everything else.
And really, except
until very recently,
I'm sure there were
nice sunny days,
and they didn't
realize how awful
it was because they didn't know
that people could conceivably
live past 15 and all
that kind of stuff.
But it was horrible.
I mean, they had no Velcro.
They had no fat-free cheese.
They had no Google.
And you had to drive
their own cars.
Can you imagine?
They didn't even
have autonomous.
Anyway, after 10,000
human generations,
we are alive, and not just alive
like in Bangladesh or Bolivia
or some lovely nice
place, but in the center
of the whole thing.
And not just in the center
of the whole thing in New
York or London or Shanghai.
But in the-- today.
I'm not normally
allowed to come here.
I'd love to get one
of those little passes
so I could come here
all the time, just
to be able to get free hot
chocolate and all that stuff.
But we are-- this is it.
After 10,000 human
generations, we
are either on the cusp of
unimaginable prosperity,
of the type actually that
we enjoy ourselves now,
but most of the
world doesn't get
to live the way you and I do.
And by the way, a cusp
is for good things.
Brink or precipice
is for bad things.
Or-- OK, politicians like
constantly, oh, we're
on the brink of-- no.
Anyway, we're on the cusp
of unimaginable prosperity,
and by the way, mortality, as
Bill Gates said 30 years ago,
it's just a software problem.
I have a small chance
of living forever,
which I'm really enjoying
that small chance.
I'm not counting on it.
But I floss, and
I do these things,
because if you play your cards
right, you could live forever.
You guys have a much
better chance than I do.
And some people, oh, who
would want to do that?
Well, I do.
Or at least I'd like to be the
one who decides when I stop.
And all shriveled up and bald?
No, if they can do mortality,
I can have as much hair
as I want, and I'll be tall
and anything I want to be.
I mean, we are at
this amazing moment.
I have magic.
I have more magic in this pocket
than Merlin ever dreamed of.
I have all the
world's knowledge,
all the world's symphonies.
I mean, the kings, czars,
we live-- it's amazing.
Or we're on the brink of
hurtling off the rails
and making the planet,
this little spaceship that
were 2 and 1/2 billion
passengers when I was born,
and there are 7.5 or 7.6
billion now-- triple.
And I'm still, as you
can see, a young man.
We really could,
between nuclear winter,
which is not a good
solution to global warming,
and bioterrorism
and all the other--
we could make this spaceship--
not probably in the next--
we won't all die in the
next 10 or 20 years.
But we could, if we don't
get on a sustainable
path in the next 10 or
20 years, it's not clear
that the cockroaches
10,000 years from now
won't be looking back
and telling little baby
cockroaches, saying, you're
not going to believe this.
But once upon a time, like a
second ago in geological time,
there was this species.
They thought they were so cool,
and they made these motels
with sticky floors
that you can check in,
but you can't check
out all that stuff.
I don't know--
actually does anybody
know roach motels anymore?
Do they still make them?
And the cockroaches
will be here,
and the planet will be
here, but we may not,
just like I think it's Easter
Island or one of those, where
the whole thing just
collapsed because they started
too much erosion from too much
firewood because there were too
many people, and it just got
out of balance, and it was over.
My feeling is, we have such a
responsibility to the 10,000
generations who suffered
and strived and did
so much ingenious thinking
and trying to figure out
whether the Moon goes around the
Earth or we go around the Sun
or what.
All those folks, we owe it
to them not to screw this up.
And to the next
10,000 generations,
we especially owe it to
them to let them have it.
So it's a huge deal
for me to come and get
to talk to you, because
you are at the center
of this whole thing.
And you're not each, I realize,
the CEO of Google or Alphabet
or whatever.
But this is a big deal.
Come on Wednesday if you can.
And for the Democrats--
I'm sorry, because I'm not
probably supposed to do this--
but if you're not going
to run for office,
then help us get some balance
back into this government.
Because the Trump vision and
the Mitch McConnell vision
and the Scott Pruitt climate
change is a hoax vision--
he runs the EPA--
this is not the way
we are on the cusp.
This is the way
we're on the brink.
OK, way too much.
I'm done.
Would anyone like
to ask a question?
And if you don't, Henry will.
HENRY HARDING:
[INAUDIBLE] in the mic
back there and the
mic back there.
That might be a
little bit too much
from a logistics standpoint
to have people get up
and walk over.
So I might just,
if it's all right,
hand this mic around to you guys
if you have specific questions
and be little Vanna
White for a second.
But I actually do have
a question to start off.
So I am not joking.
I want to hear about
the password hint.
So to the extent that you
claim that you've invented it,
that's my primary inquiry.
ANDY TOBIAS: To
the extent that I
claim I'm the best little boy
in the world, I never lie.
So you've all heard of Quicken.
Before Quicken, there was Andrew
Tobias' Managing Your Money.
And I only brought one
version of it because--
this you've probably
never seen-- in the book
that I wrote under a pen
name, I disguised everything.
I didn't really go to Yale.
I went to Harvard,
but I made it Yale.
That makes it a novel.
So people say, are you going
to write another novel?
I never wrote a
first, any novel.
It's hard to write a novel.
I don't have the
talent to do that.
They say, of course you did.
You say, changing it from
Harvard to Yale doesn't make it
a novel.
Changing Henry's name to
Harry doesn't make it a novel.
Anyway, so I changed the
company I worked for to IBM
to show that I was--
because I went to
Harvard Business School,
and that was kind of
IBM-ish, and straight-laced,
and suit and tie, and
all this kind of stuff.
And then, ironically, my
software, Managing Your Money,
IBM did--
anybody heard of the PCjr?
There was a thing--
how old are you?
You've got to be like 100.
So it was on Apple too, and
it was on the very first Mac
and all that kind of stuff.
And it was on the IBM
PC with floppy disks.
Has anybody seen
a 5 and 1/4 inch?
This is a 5 and 1/4
inch floppy disk.
We had people calling
in the help desk
to try to cut them
with scissors.
Anyway, but the
PCjr was terrible.
I mean, IBM did a
terrible job with it.
But my face was on the front,
and I'm an IBM part number.
And this was the cartridge that
you would put it in the PCjr.
So for a minute, I have no--
I can't program anything.
I can't code.
I know a little bit about, if
you have an open parentheses,
you really--
if, then, else, you better
have a close parentheses
and all this kind of stuff.
But I just had the great
job of saying, well,
could it have a word
processor inside too?
And then they would go off,
and we designed our own word
processor, has commands that are
completely different from Word
Perfect back then or Word.
Could it do your taxes?
How about life expectancy?
I'd like to have it tell
me how long I can live.
It was fantastic, this software.
We decided it should be
password protected, because you
got all your
checking stuff on it,
and you got all your stock
portfolios and stuff.
But what if you forget your
password or you lose it?
So they were going to do this
thing where, I think by then,
they would give you four choices
of where you go to high school
or whatever.
I'm not even sure they had that.
I think maybe you just
put in your password,
and if you forgot it,
you were out of luck.
I can't remember.
But I said to this
wonderful guy, Jerry Rubin,
who deserves all
the credit for this.
I said, Jerry, why
don't we do this?
Why don't we let them
say their password,
and then they can put
in a hint and say,
it's the name of the dog
that we had up at the beach,
or whatever the hint is where
they'll definitely remember,
because they wrote
their hint themselves.
And he said, OK,
we could do that.
And we did.
And it's still a good way to
do it, and a lot of places
don't do that.
And yes, I invented
the password hint.
And yes, I forgot to patent it.
And if I had patented
it, I wouldn't
need to ask you to
come to this thing,
because I could just pay for
the whole election myself.
So I did.
HENRY HARDING: OK, so
with that, a question.
I'm just going to hand
her the mic, I think.
Walking back there is going
to be way too awkward.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much
for coming here.
This has been really great.
I have a quick question more
to do with the political side
of your life.
ANDY TOBIAS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Which is that as
all the people in this room
are looking at their own
forms of political engagement
with the current
administration, if you see,
given your experience
in the field,
if there are
particular engagement
strategies with administrations
like this one that you think
are more effective than
others, particularly
coming from individuals
who are LGBTQ--
I think that's probably a
representative constituency
in here--
and who may find that this
administration is extremely
hostile to them and to
their families, what
have you seen as infective,
really effective engagement
strategies for people
like us to be able to use
in administration like this?
ANDY TOBIAS: Well,
none of us really
has that much experience
with administration
like this because
there's never been one.
You can look back to
1933 in another country
and try to get a sense of
what that would be like.
I have a little column every
day at andrewtobias.com,
and tomorrow's talks
pretty directly
about some of that stuff.
But I think the good
news on our issue, which
is a very important issue to us,
and it's a very important issue
to the country, but it's not an
existential issue for mankind,
I think the good news is
the cat is out of the bag,
or the toothpaste out
of the tube or whatever.
Enough Americans, even
including Republicans,
not necessarily
Republicans in Congress,
but enough Americans and enough
people in the civilized world
have opened their hearts,
and gotten to know us,
and opened their minds that,
especially among young people--
not that we mustn't
always be vigilant,
and not that we're
entirely there yet,
because we're not
entirely there yet.
And we're certainly
not entirely there yet
in Mississippi or Uganda,
which Uganda is not
part of the civilized
world, and Mississippi is.
But they need to get
further along with us.
But I think in
terms of our stuff,
we want to just keep supporting
HRC and the task force
and GLSEN and Lambda
and all these things,
and, frankly, Democrats.
Because all the
progress we've made
has, from the beginning
of this effort,
which was basically in the '60s
is sort of when it started,
Democrats pretty quickly became
almost unanimously on our side.
There were Southern Democrats
not so much at first,
and there were
issues and all that.
But basically, especially
in the last 20 years,
when all these progress
legislatively happened,
Democrats are
unanimously with us.
And Republicans, not out in the
countryside, human Republicans,
but the ones who were elected
in Congress, especially
with the extreme polarization
from all the gerrymandering
and why everything
has gotten more,
they have to appeal to their
most extreme base and all
that, Republicans
have been blocking us
on everything, every
step of the way,
and continue to,
to a large extent.
And there will be judges
that Trump gets confirmed--
hopefully not Gorsuch.
One of my gay friends is
one of his best friends,
and he assures me
he's a lovely guy.
And I'm sure he is
a lovely guy, but he
believes that
corporations are people
and all this kind of stuff.
So I think-- and I
don't get a commission.
And I don't want to
be an ambassador.
I'm not even treasurer
anymore after 18 years,
but I am getting
paid on Wednesday.
At the annual LGBT dinner,
after 18 years at $1 a year,
they're going to
give me a 5-foot--
bigger than this
screen, I think.
I'm looking for like 5 feet
by 2 and 1/2 foot check
for 18 years at $1 a year.
We're haggling
over the interest,
because it seems to me I
should get interest, right?
But this dinner,
where last year we
had Hillary and
Barbara Streisand,
and in the three previous
years we had President Obama,
we kind of took it for granted.
Of course the president
of the United States
would come and talk to the
LGBT Democratic fundraiser.
This year we got Joe
Biden, and Whoopi Goldberg,
and Jane Lynch,
and Billy Porter,
and Barney Frank's
going to be there,
and David Mixner is
and Ambassador Hormel,
who was the very
first openly gay
ambassador in America
ever to be an ambassador.
And now we have like seven,
or we did until Trump.
Anyway, so I don't
say this because I
get a commission on it.
And I don't want a job.
But I actually believe,
biased though I might be,
that actually to
support Democrats,
or to run for
office, but I don't
want to have you leave Google
before your option's best.
To run for office
would be great.
To support friends
and people that
inspire you to run for office
would be great, especially
in places that are purple.
If you get a chance
to be assigned
to North Carolina for Google
or something like that,
we need your vote there, not
quite so much in New York.
But to be involved in politics,
and to be respectful of people
who don't agree with us.
Hillary, at last year's dinner,
I was as far from Hillary as I
am from you, [INAUDIBLE],,
when she said--
she had pneumonia.
We didn't know it at the time.
But that was that period
she had pneumonia.
And she was with friends--
granted 800 friends, and there
was press there, I guess,
and so she shouldn't
have said this.
But she said that thing about
the basket of the deplorables,
that half the people
voting for Trump are,
and the other half are--
it was a dumb and
unfortunate thing to say.
And even that little thing--
there were much bigger factors,
but that alone might have been
enough to change the thing.
But with a few exceptions--
obviously virulent racists are
deplorable--
but most people who voted
for Trump are not deplorable.
They were bamboozled.
And we need to talk to them with
respect, which they deserve,
and not tell them that they're
idiots, which they're not.
But they have sure been fooled
by Rush Limbaugh and Glenn Beck
and Fox News and Roger Ailes--
I'm not even sure how much
peace he should rest in--
and Trump, who has
told us, not only
are we going to get
tired of winning.
I mean, we're going to
be winning so much we're
going to get tired of winning.
We are going to have great
health care, as I guess all
you do because we're at Google.
But great health care,
not for the same price.
Everybody's going to
have great health care.
And not just less,
at a fraction--
nay-- and how often you hear
nay anymore, other than a horse?
Nay, at a tiny
fraction of the cost.
These are his words.
You are going to have
great health care
at a tiny fraction of the cost.
It's 1933 all over again.
How many of you
know that Trump kept
a book of Hitler's speeches
by his bedside for years?
Nobody, it's amazing.
So my friend Marie Brenner
wrote a profile of him
for "Vanity Fair" about
17 or 18 years ago.
And his ex-wife,
Ivana, told her that.
And she said, what?
He kept a book of
Hitler's speeches?
What?
She said, yeah, it's in my
divorce attorney's safe.
You want to see the book?
And so she goes to Donald--
and by the way, I
call him Donald.
I have friends
who golf with him.
I have friends who--
one of his bankers
is a friend of mine.
When he was just Donald
Trump, OK, not my cup of tea,
but go ahead.
Be Donald Trump.
But to run the world?
No.
So anyway, Maria goes to
Donald and says, what?
Is this true?
You have a book of Hitler's
speeches by your bedside?
And he got all defensive.
He said, well,
first of all, Marie,
it's not a book of
Hitler's speeches.
It's "Mein Kampf."
OK, great.
You've got "Mein Kampf"
by your bedside, OK.
And second, it was a
gift to me by the head
of Paramount Pictures, a
Hollywood movie studio,
and he's Jewish.
So give me a break, Marie.
So Marie goes to
Marty Davis, who
is the head of Paramount
Pictures at the time.
He's since met his ward.
And what about it, Marty?
As so Marty says,
well, first of all,
even though it doesn't
matter, and even
though I do run a Hollywood
studio, I'm not Jewish.
And second, no, it
wasn't "Mein Kampf."
It's a book of Hitler's
speeches called "My New Order."
So, A, that's true.
And B, I went on after I--
and "Vanity Fair" then
republished all this last year.
And it was in "Vanity
Fair," and I wrote about it
about 1,000 times in my
column, which six people read.
Thank you and you and you.
It was seven until
my mom passed on.
But anyway, so, I mean,
it's been out there,
and some people know this.
And by the way, if you're like
the head of marketing for P&G
or something, that's
an interesting thing
to have by your bedside,
because how do you
influence mass psychology,
and how do you--
OK?
And it's not dispositive.
I'm not saying that
Trump is Hitler.
But I'm not sure Hitler
wanted to be Hitler when he--
he just wanted to make America--
I mean, make Germany great
again and get China and Mexico--
I mean, get England and
France's boot off his neck.
You know, and get
rid of the Jews--
I mean, I'm sorry, the Muslims.
You know, I mean,
some parallels.
This is scary stuff.
Oh, so I went on eBay,
and I bought the book.
And I now have the
book by my bedside.
And I haven't read
the actual speeches.
It's a lot of speeches,
and I'm a real slow reader.
But the introduction and the
forward, one by a French guy
and one by a British, the
book came out in 1941.
And the copy I have, I told this
story last night to a friend
who said, is it signed?
Is it autographed?
No, it's not
autographed by Hitler.
But the forward and
the introduction
tackled the question of, as
you read the speeches that
follow, what is
there about this that
allowed this man to be
democratically elected
in 1933, which he was?
He didn't have 50% of the
vote, but he had enough.
Neither did Trump.
He had enough.
And you read these analyses,
descriptions of his rhetoric
and his style, and
you say, oh my god.
And so I took some
of the excerpts
and put them on my little
blog post thing every day.
I put them on this
blog post, and I didn't
say what they were about.
And everybody assumed I
was writing about Trump
and that I was taking an ex--
little bit stilted language.
Well, yeah, it was from
1941, and they wrote a little
differently.
One was British.
So I don't want to
make too much of that,
but this is a time like
no other in our history.
And we may somehow get out
of it and right ourselves
before too much
more damage is done.
But an awful lot of damage
has already been done.
Around the world,
I have no problem.
China's great.
Russia would be
lovely if they didn't
have a journalist-murdering
and autocrat,
kleptocrat, plutocrat.
But China's fine.
But they're picking up the
slack that we're-- we're losing
our ability to help
lead the world,
which isn't necessarily
great for us.
But it's also not
great for the world,
because the world
needs sober leadership.
In Barack Obama, I think we
had the most solid, cerebral,
sensible, wonderful
leader of my lifetime
and in a long, long time.
And Clinton, other than a
couple of obvious issues,
was terrific as well.
I don't think Bush
was in that league.
And Trump is in a whole--
it's a whole other ball game.
This is not American democracy.
This is a big problem.
If anybody is brave enough
to ask another question,
it will be the yes or no answer.
HENRY HARDING: Does anyone
have another question
they want to offer up here?
I saw your hand previously.
AUDIENCE: So how often
do you encounter people
telling you your first
book changed their lives?
ANDY TOBIAS: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: How often to you run
into people who came to you,
say your first book
changed their lives?
ANDY TOBIAS: Well, every
once in a while it happens.
And it's the nicest--
way better than any royalties
ever could have been.
AUDIENCE: Was it translated
into different languages?
ANDY TOBIAS: No, and I kind of--
well, yes, it was translated by
someone from Google, actually.
It was translated into Romanian.
So I get an email.
People don't-- sometimes
I'll meet somebody in person.
Other times it's an
email or something,
including a guy
who just came-- you
know, people are still just
coming out when they're 48
or whatever.
It's amazing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it was given to me
as a gift when I first came out.
ANDY TOBIAS: Really.
AUDIENCE: Somebody
older than me.
Well, he was 30 at that time.
ANDY TOBIAS: Yes, old.
AUDIENCE: He was like,
this book changed my life.
I hope we change yours as well.
ANDY TOBIAS: Well,
it's very gratifying.
And so this guy from Romania--
I think only five people
have read it in Romanian.
I'd love to see it in Spanish
or some other languages.
And one other thing
to say about that
is, so I used to get these
wonderful hand-written letters
or typewritten letters
in the '70s and the '80s.
You wrote the story of my life,
and all this kind of stuff.
They were very nice letters.
And then Amazon was invented,
and it had five stars,
and it made me feel
really good, or 4 and 1/2,
or whatever it had.
It was very nice.
And then I stopped
looking for a long time.
And I looked back maybe
10 years ago or something,
and it was down to three stars.
And there were all
these one-star reviews.
And at first, you know,
desperate for love
before all other
things, I think, oh no.
This is terrible.
Basically, they were
saying, what a dick.
I mean, this guy,
he was a homophobe,
and he is so impressed
with himself,
and he's a dreadful person.
Why do people like this
book and all this stuff?
And at first I was
a little crushed.
And then I realized-- maybe
this is just a rationalization--
but I realized, this is great.
This is really a wonderful
barometer of how much progress
we've made.
Because today's kids cannot--
I mean, they can process.
They're real smart.
But they can't fully grasp
how different the world was.
And even some of my
peers have forgotten.
Because now you go back and
you read it, and you think,
yeah, what a dick.
But the world was
very different.
And I agree.
I was a dick.
But we evolve.
And anyway, so the third one,
hopefully people won't think
I'm--
well, they probably will.
But anyway, thank
you for the question.
And I'm glad you--
HENRY HARDING: More
questions right up here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I hate to
take it back to the election.
But I wanted to ask you, since
you're a Democratic Party
insider, for lack of a better
term, if you could give us
your thoughts on what you
think really transpired
and what steps the party's
taking in terms of a postmortem
to make sure something like
this doesn't happen again?
ANDY TOBIAS: Great question.
You know, a lot
of things happen,
and here's how I would rank why
this unbelievable perfect storm
tragedy happened.
The most important thing
is, without ill intent,
the media assured everybody that
this man had absolutely no path
to 270.
So if you stay home,
not a big thing.
If you vote for Jill Stein
or Gary Johnson, not going to
change the world.
If you even want to do a
little-- forgive my language--
a little fuck you to whatever.
I'm not happy.
I mean, of course I don't
want Trump, but I'm not happy,
and you should know it,
so I'll vote for him just
to kind of let-- you
know, because he's not
going to be president, so
it's safe to vote for him.
If a million people out of the
63 million who voted for Trump
were in that last category,
and of the 9 million
who voted for Johnson
and Stein half of them
wouldn't have thrown
their votes away
if they realized this man could
actually become president,
and if the 10 or 15
million who didn't turn out
to vote because, you
know, why do I have to?
If they hadn't been assured
that he couldn't win,
she would have had
80 million votes,
and he would have
had 62 million.
And that would have been enough.
You know, even in
the Bush-Gore world
and in the electoral college,
she would have won handily.
So that's the first
thing in my view.
And that wasn't nefarious.
That was just terrible.
But when you have
the former KGB,
when you have
thousands of agents
and a concerted,
intentional, sustained attack
on our country to try to
destabilize our country, which
is happening, and destabilize
the world, which is happening,
I do take issue.
I kind of understand
it, but I take issue
with those of our talking
heads who go on TV
and they say, now, I'm
not saying it would
have changed the election.
Well, of course it would
I mean, you couldn't
have gotten--
77,000 votes didn't
happen because people
reading Facebook fake stuff
from KGB kind of people.
They're reading how
horrible Hillary is,
and they're getting
it reinforced.
I mean, you guys know
a lot more about how
all these things work.
But you do no evil, and Putin
is all about doing evil.
So that was a huge
thing, I think.
And then the last big piece--
well, so the third one that's
smaller, but still very
meaningful and a little
bit related to this,
is the Comey stuff and the
way the media played it.
This email thing is as big a
deal as Russia attacking us.
These are two equivalent things.
Each one is a scandal.
We've got to be even handed.
We don't want to lose readership
or whatever the reason is.
And we want to have a dog fight.
So the Comey stuff, I don't
think it was intentional,
but it was a big problem.
And then finally, I mean,
the basket of deplorables
sitting eight feet from
me, that was kind of
like the 47% comment
that Romney did.
And Romney's not a--
boy, if we could have
Romney instead of Trump,
Romney is a smart,
sane guy who, you know,
et cetera, et cetera, not
my first choice, but OK.
Anyway, so those were
the things that did it.
Now the party, one area that
Barack Obama was not great at,
because he did have
a lot on his plate,
and not everybody is perfect
in every way, and nobody
that I know, is he didn't pay
too much attention to the DNC.
And having a lovely woman,
who is a friend of mine
and all that, Debbie
Wasserman Schultz,
but having a part-time chair of
the party for four years, who
also has a mother of
three, and was Congress,
this was not a good idea.
This was an opportunity
to really build the party
and build leadership and
do all sorts of things.
Now we have a really dynamic
chair, who I don't think--
I mean, his strongest suit is
not TV, which is unfortunate,
because that's how
most people know him.
And so Tom Perez, if
you've seen him on TV,
you hopefully say, guy's got
a lot of fight, which he does.
And he's smart, and he's for
all the right things, all great.
Somehow it's not Bill
Clinton's communication skills
or whatever.
But he is really good.
And I got calls from way up
in the Obama administration,
people saying, of all the
cabinet secretaries we had,
Tom was either the best or tied
for first with two or three
other people.
He was labor secretary.
So we have a great chair who
was working 80 hours a week.
We've just hired a lesbian
CEO named Jess O'Connell, who
ran EMILY's List until
a couple weeks ago
and expanded its membership
from 3 million to 5 million.
By the way, for those of you
who are either LGBT or allies--
I mean, I actually
find this a little--
I mean, I'm not sure we should
have everybody know this,
but there are nine
officers of the DNC.
Three of them, the finance
chair, the treasurer-- not me,
the new one that I recruited--
and the secretary are all LGBT,
as is the CEO.
So we kind of own the
place and run the place.
And those of you who can,
you should come on Wednesday
at 6 o'clock.
And Henry or whatever,
or ask me after class,
and we'll sign you up.
And yes, you'll have to mortgage
the studio that you've just
finally got that studio.
Oh my god.
Or just wait to renovate
the kitchenette.
Are there any 40-somethings
who work here?
HENRY HARDING: No.
We have two minutes
left, so I want
to be sensitive if there's one
speedy question that anyone
has.
OK, yes.
AUDIENCE: I have one now.
How do you change people?
You talked before about
talking to purple states.
But how do you just change
people's opinion on things?
How do you make people
understand LGBT, understand
climate change?
It shouldn't be
a partisan issue.
ANDY TOBIAS: Well, yeah, so I
mean that's a great question.
And on LGBT, the way is
just to get to know them.
Nobody could know
you and not like you.
But that's largely
it is just say,
so what rights would
you like me to have,
and which ones
should I not have?
But not in a--
I mean, I tend to
get confrontational,
and I get sarcastic, and all
the things you shouldn't get.
But there's a guy named
Richard Viguerie who
is the father of right-wing
conservative direct mail,
and I've been going
to the same thing
each year for like 30 years, I
think on Renaissance weekend.
And I see Richard.
He's incredibly
genial and all that.
But he is a very
devout Catholic.
And I said to him once, with 300
people in an audience, I said,
Richard--
and Charles was
with me at the time,
and a lot of people like
Charles and all that.
I said, I know you feel
very strongly about this.
So just pretend for a minute you
can have it any way you want.
What rights do you want
Charles and me to have,
and what rights can we not have?
And just tell us,
what do you think?
Well, let me think about that.
I'll talk to you next
year about it or whatever.
And then next year came,
and he didn't talk about it.
So the LGBT one--
on the climate change,
you've got tribes.
And you got people who
only watch Fox and only,
all this kind of stuff.
But we don't have to
get 100% of the vote.
I mean, it would
be wonderful if we
can change the educational
system and get more people to--
and begin to-- it's
such a big topic,
and obviously there
are no easy answers.
But it is important
to realize that we
haven't failed if we only
get more votes than they get.
At least that gives us a
chance to have our agenda work,
and give people health care,
and have them not want it taken
away, and stuff like that.
Anyway, you're great to come,
and thank you for Google.
And it's a miracle, Google.
I mean, it's totally
changed my life.
I've been writing
about this forever.
I mean, it's a miracle.
I don't know how it
works, but it's a miracle.
So thank you.
HENRY HARDING: Let's give
him a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]